[Music]
if we could celebrate
every breath
that we take
because nothing's a guarantee
if we could celebrate the breath
and the exhale
which is
being alive
because i
was self-medicating i was trying to numb
myself i was trying to
calm the circus i was trying to calm the
brain i was trying to
feel better
than i did and
it's okay to not be okay
it's just not okay to stay that way
those days when i'm tired or
worn out or
just basically sick of the grind
what do i do on those days i go anyways
i get it done even
if i'm just going through the motions
i go through the motions
i don't really want to work out i work
out i really don't want to hammer on a
project
i hammer on the project don't really
want to get up and get out of bed i get
up and get out of bed
these could be signals that you need
some time off and those signals might be
right they could be correct but
don't take today off not today wait
until tomorrow don't give in to the
immediate gratification that is
whispering in your ear
shut that down do not listen to that
little voice instead go through the
motions lift the weights sprint the hill
work on the project get out of bed
as an overall rule i do not like
procrastination you need to get things
done
but if you are going to rest that is one
thing that you should procrastinate on
that's the one thing i want you to put
off until tomorrow and when tomorrow
comes you still feel like you need
to rest or you need to take a break then
okay take it but the chances are
you won't you won't need that rest
chances are you will realize that the
desire to rest was just weakness it was
just the desire to take the path
of least resistance the downhill path
the easy path
and by simply going through the motions
you overcame that path and you stayed on
the righteous path the disciplined path
i think one must tempt the possibility
of
falling flat on your face so after that
fight when i lost and i'm looking at all
these people and they're all celebrating
my demise and saying i'm done and this
and
it certainly lit a fire under my belly
every single person dealt with me every
single fighter dealt with me doubt me
now
how long have you been working on your
dreams and you have nothing to show this
is all you got to show people going to
do that to you and some people ladies
and gentlemen they stop because they
don't see instant results it doesn't
happen quickly they stop oh no no no no
you got to keep on watering your dream
and when it began to happen they stopped
laughing whoa look look here it's hey
man you know i know you could do it look
at you got a job here see during those
hard times
we didn't know how you're going to make
payroll during those times when you fail
and things didn't work out they were
they were nowhere to be found
you know what i discovered when you were
working at your dream somebody said the
harder the battle the sweeter the
victory oh it's sweet to you it's good
to you why see when you when it's hard
there's a struggle see what you become
in the process is more important in the
dream that's far more important the kind
of person you become the character that
you built the courage that you develop
the faith that you're manifesting oh
it's it's something that you get up in
the morning you look yourself in the
mirror you're a different kind of person
you walk with a different kind of spirit
and people know
that you know what life is that you have
embraced life
you know it was hard
but you did it hard
and when you get to the point where all
you want to do is be successful as bad
as you want to breathe then you'll be
successful and i'm here to tell you
number one that most of you say you want
to be successful but you don't want it
bad you just kind of want it you don't
want it bad than you want to party you
don't want it as much as you want to be
cool you most of you don't want success
as much as you want to sleep some of you
love sleep more than you love success
and i'm here to tell you today if you're
going to be successful you've got to be
willing to give up sleep you got to be
willing to work off for three hours of
sleep two hours if you really want to be
successful some days you're gonna have
to stay up three days in a row because
if you go to sleep you might miss the
opportunity to be successful that's how
bad you gotta want it listen to me you
gotta wanna be successful so bad that
you forget to eat in any
area of your life that you wanna change
any
there's one fact that you need to know
just one you're never gonna feel like it
ever no one's coming motivation isn't
happening you're never going to feel
like it most people are hungry to
achieve a certain amount make a certain
amount of money and then they get
comfortable and relax or to get a
certain level of fitness and then they
relax you have to accept
that all your excuses are lies
they are lies all of them think about
the things
that you tell yourself the lies you use
to rationalize taking the easy road and
leaving discipline behind
think about them
you don't have time that's a lie you
don't have
support
that's a lie you don't have the
equipment or the gear lies you don't
know the best way who cares that's a lie
or you're too old or you're too young of
course you're too old or too young why
and there's
you're too
busy sure you are
[Music]
and you're too tired or you're too sore
or you're just plain not feeling it lies
lies lies and the list goes on and on
and on
and it doesn't stop
if you don't make it stop so
recognize
recognize
the excuses are not valid they aren't
they're trumped up they're conjured up
they're fabricated they're lies and how
do you stop the lies you stop the lies
with the truth
the truth will set you free the truth
will stand and the truth will deliver
you from
procrastination and laziness and the
downward spiral that comes with a lack
of discipline
so
don't believe the lies believe the truth
but the truth is you have time you have
the skill you have the knowledge and the
support and the willpower and the
discipline to get it done
so get out of your head
your feelings are screwing you i don't
care how you feel when it comes to what
you want you will not get it
because you will never feel like it and
you need to get outside your comfort
zone it's not about taking risks it's
about getting
outside your comfort zone those first
three seconds when you push yourself out
of bed they blow
but once you're up
it's great whenever i face anything
that's challenging when any ever
anything
sucks
i like it it's gonna make me tougher
it's going to give me a good story to
tell it's going to toughen my mind it's
going to bring us together as a you know
what military training is you know how
they form a bond in military groups they
make you do stuff that sucks that's what
they do so when something sucks good
it's going to make me tougher and it's
going to make us stronger so bring it
most of you won't be successful because
when you're studying and you get tired
you quit and i'm here to tell you today
if you guys somebody came in my office
the other day crying i said look don't
cry to give up try to keep going
don't cry to quit
you already in pain you already hurt get
a reward from it don't go to sleep until
you succeed
[Music]
so i say
[Music]
take ownership take extreme ownership
don't make excuses don't blame any other
person or any other thing get control of
your ego don't
hide your delicate pride
from the truth
take ownership of everything in your
world the good and the bad
take ownership of your mistakes take
ownership of your shortfalls take
ownership of your problems and then take
ownership of the solutions that will get
those problems solved
take ownership of your mission take
ownership of your job
of your team of your future and take
ownership of your life